N0thing is one of NA’s biggest CS:GO players.
(Casting)
But what does it mean to be the best in NA?
To be perennially at the top of a region that can’t compete with the scene’s top international talent?
(Casting)
What becomes of your legacy when winning is almost always just out of reach?
What becomes of your legacy, when the team you helped build finally wins without you?
Across a decade of playing CS professionally, N0thing saw it all.
The highs, the lows, and every crushing loss in between.
And yet, his legacy has remained untarnished.
This is his story.
Jordan “n0thing” Gilbert was born on October 25, 1990 in San Diego, California, and was
the youngest of three brothers.
Like many of today’s esports pros, n0thing got his start in his game of choice by watching
his brother, Jared, play Counter-Strike.
But even before that, n0thing always had a flare for competition, and wasn’t going
to let other kids walk all over him.
"We joined this little roller hockey league, kids were kinda picking on him a little bit
so I went over to kind of protect him a little bit and he pushed me back and he goes "I got this.""
But at home, n0thing was obsessed with video games, specifically, Counter-Strike 1.6.
"I home schooled Jordan for the 12 years he was in school,
on his off time he wanted to play video games.
How could I say no when he was doing all of his work.
When I saw how effortlessly he was improving and growing so fast,
I just decided that I was going to go as far as he wanted to go with it."
He was playing 10-12 hours of CS a day, nonstop, and then going out to small LAN tournaments
and rolling people.
The only problem was that n0thing was much younger than his adult opponents.
"A lot of the older kids that were playing did not like the fact that they were getting waxed by
a nine or ten year old player so his older brother stood by to make sure things didn't get out of hand, which they
did a few times."
N0thing knew that the only way to make it big was to play as much as possible in front
of as many people as possible, so he leaned on his mother, who drove him to LAN after
LAN, all on n0thing’s quest to become the best.
"So one of the biggest things for me, succeeding in the local scene and probably getting the opportunities
I did.
"Was getting notoriety from competing in tournaments in LA and Las Vegas.
And my mom was a key factor in getting me there."
And it t all paid off a few years later, when N0thing signed with Evil Geniuses at just
18 years old.
"So at that point Amazing Gaming won the KODE5 qualifier and got picked up by Evil Geniuses.
And that was my first pro contract that actually had a salary and they gave me gear and stuff."
For the next four years, EG were the best North American 1.6 team.
They won the ESEA Season 3 Finals, the IEM IV American Finals, the ESEA Season 5 Finals,
ESEA Season 6 Finals and the Beat It!
2010 Finals.
But when it came to international competition, EG always faltered.
(Casting)
All the while, n0thing was developing a reputation.
He had an aggressive, high-octane style that made him thrilling to watch, and his young
age made his Wunderkind status all the more impressive.
"I'm gonna be showing you guys today a bit about M4 gun control and just showing you the different aspects
of it and basically all the different battling techniques, you'll need for the different distances,
and situations you'll encounter."
But after so many years atop NA, EG finally crumbled in 2011.
The team fell to 9th-10th at IEM Hannover, then failed to make it out of groups at IEM
VI Global Challenge New York, and capped off the year by placing third at the WCG Pan-American
tournament.
During that same time, N0thing was pretty uncertain about his life.
EG was paying him a salary, but it wasn't enough to live off.
So he started going to college and even got a marketing internship at Gunnar.
But the internship, just made him jealous.
"It was kind of a weird blow to me ego because I was like dealing into the gaming industry
but in like this behind the scenes way, I was like helping other pro gamers from League and StarCraft
do cool stuff. I remember being jealous, like "Man I wish my game had more traction."
Evil Geniuses left Counter-Strike in January 2012, disbanding their team after months of
rumors and speculation.
That left n0thing in the lurch.
1.6 was on the way out, and CS:GO, the game’s
sequel, was quickly becoming the game of choice.
But GO wasn’t perfect and, when it came out, n0thing wasn’t even sure if he liked it.
"I hate how in CS:GO, they made it more about "strategy"."
"And less about f*cking just easy, like in 1.6 the recoil was obviously easier to control,
But the strategy was much more prevalent cause you could actually hold angles, you can't just f*cking
run up like an idiot by yourself. This game, f*cking pure idiot bait, just works everywhere."
But  what n0thing didn’t realize at that time,
was that CS:GO was perfect for him.
"Very early on there was a clip of him like, actually kind of criticising certain aspects of the game
And while he's talking and having a conversation, he's just casually getting four kills in a round.
Just running forward you know, it just seemed so effortless to him. So we all thought that Jordan would
just be incredible at this game because it just seemed to fit his style so much."
N0thing bounced around  several rosters as CS:GO started to gain traction,
playing with some of NA’s best rising talent. His last team, Team Dynamic, was quickly noticed
and signed by long-running esports org CompLexity Gaming.
The team played in the first two CS:GO Majors, brand new tournaments with massive prize pools
funded by Valve, making into the Top 8 both times.
And n0thing was popping off.
(Casting)
After just a few of months of playing GO, that complexity roster changed hands again.
This time they were acquired by up-and-coming
esports org Cloud9, the team that n0thing
would spend the rest of his professional career with.
CS:GO was growing in ways that 1.6 could never match.
Esports was growing at a rapid pace thanks to growing prize pool, more interest from
sponsors and increased viewership on Twitch.
That meant there was a legion of brand new CS fans, kids who never played CS 1.6, and
were looking for a team to love.
And Cloud9 gave NA fans that team.
(Casting)
The team was among the best in NA in those early days of CS:GO, but perhaps more importantly,
n0thing was providing fans with a look behind the curtain.
"What do you gotta say right now."
"All-star game's going live in about 30 minutes."
"What do you think we're gonna win by?"
"16-1?"
"Robin are you playing? Are you playing all-star game?"
N0thing would constantly vlog and take behind-the-scenes videos early on in CS:GO, endearing himself
to fans, and bringing them closer to the team and his goofy personality.
"Bout to get on another plane,
Going to Stockholm to play a lot of CS and
get insane."
Unfortunately, that was a lot of what there was to like about C9.
They were one of NA’s best, but just like EG, they crumbled in the face of international
competition.
(Casting)
Cloud9 placed 9th-12th at
DreamHack Winter and ESL One Katowice 2015, and until the Spring, they continued to be
stymied by European teams at every tournament they attended.
In April, C9 made a switch, bringing on Skadoodle and Freakazoid to replace Shahzam and Semphis.
Then, after a few weeks of feeling out the roster, they were suddenly on the upswing.
(Casting)
And they weren’t just the best team in NA, they were finally hanging with the European teams.
Unfortunately, they weren’t winning.
(Casting)
Cloud9 were the undisputed best team in NA and while they could compete internationally,
they weren’t ever able to push themselves the rest of the way past the finish line.
(Casting)
That summer, they were perennially second-place finishers, behind the European teams that
beat them, time and time again.
The summer of C9 came to an end at the two Majors that fall, as C9 placed 9th-12th back-to-back
at both ESL One Cologne 2015
(Casting)
DreamHack Cluj-Napoca 2015.
Shortly thereafter, team captain SeanGares left the team, and was replaced for the 2016 season.
And, at least for the first few months, the roster move didn’t go according to plan.
(Casting)
At MLG Columbus, Cloud9 watched as Team Liquid rose up and placed 3rd-4th, the highest finish
an NA team had ever attained at a Major.
Meanwhile, Cloud9 were out in dead last.
C9’s place as NA’s best team was officially taken over, and the team went into a roster
freefall.
They lost Freakazoid, added adreN, then Slemmy,
then Autimatic, all while getting rid of their
manager and coach.
The Cloud9 that ruled NA was well and truly done.
In its place, there was a new Cloud9, one that, for a while, looked pretty solid.
(Casting)
They were a team that could once again, compete with the top international teams.
But they couldn’t win.
(Casting)
At least, not until the ESL Pro League Season 4 Finals.
Cloud9 went on a tear at the EPL Season 4 Finals, and in a complete upset,
brought down home-town favourites SK Gaming in front of a crowd of cheering Brazilian fans.
(Casting)
"I'm trying not to cry, I've played this game for a long time. To beat these guys here means a lot to me,
and my team played amazing you know.
I can say all the cliche things right now I'm just really f*cking excited."
Things were looking up for Cloud9.
They made it into the Atlanta Major closed qualifier, and were back to playing well in NA,
despite their continued failures internationally.
But n0thing helped C9 claw their way back up the ladder.
They beat SK again at the Subaru Invitational, qualified for the Major with a first place
finish at the minor and 3rd-5th at the closed qualifier, and even took a shocking second-place
finish at ESL One Cologne 2017.
(Casting)
But once again, it all came crashing down at the Major.
Cloud9 left the Krakow Major in 9th-11th place.
Not dead last this time, but not good enough to guarantee a spot in the next Major.
They needed a change, and all eyes were on its oldest members.
On August 15, 2017, just a month after their catastrophic Major exit, Cloud9 dropped Shroud
and n0thing, the last remaining founding member of C9’s CS:GO team.
"And so I had a feeling it was one or the other, it was either we were going to make a change with someone
else, or we're gonna make a change with you. So he said it, I said "Alright baby, that's all I need to know."
It almost was a relief because we were almost in this limbo for a while as a team.
We needed something to change.
Shroud, for his part, had been talking about retirement for over a year, and was ready
to live the streaming lifestyle.
"In my eyes, I'm actually set for 2018."
"Are you trolling?"
"No I'm serious, I've told pretty much everyone this. Like one more solid year."
But n0thing approached things differently.
He had been playing CS professionally for over a decade when he got benched, for perhaps
the first time in his entire life.
He had gone from wunderkind superstar, to
early CS:GO adopter, to beloved personality
and then all of a sudden, people thought he
was washed up.
"Kind of sad to see n0thing go out, but I guess, like even if you're a critic of Tarik
Tarik for n0thing obviously still feels like an upgrade for me, and Rush I think is f*cking mental.
I think he's insanely good."
Meanwhile, his contract with Cloud9 meant that he wasn’t able to play for another
team until May 2018, nearly a year away.
So he decided to double down on bringing his personality to the fans.
"About to go zipline, we're about to go eat lunch actually. She's pretty scared. I've done it before done in
South America?"
"Well it's going to be fun, so hopefully we get some good shots on the helmet.
If not I'll be really sad, maybe I'll sneak the gopro in my pocket if I can't fit it on the mount.
And then just whip it out and record."
That meant more streaming
(Stream)
And even getting in front of the camera as an analyst.
"Dude VP's always had for quite a while a playbook.
When they were in their prime it was pretty wild to play them on maps like Cobble cause they
almost had a different playbook depending on who they played."
But while he was re-defining his identity in the CS scene, Cloud9 was redefining their own identity in CS.
"I don't expect us to win every tournament, I don't expect us to make it out of groups every time.
I do expect us to compete at a really high level though, making it hard for the teams to beat us.
Making us unpredictable, maybe grabbing a few wins here and there, hopefully we can win the Major.
After falling apart in Krakow, the new roster was sharp, and went on a tear.
3rd-4th at ESL One New York
ELEAGUE
(Casting)
And IEM Oakland.
"Alright then the semifinal's about to happen. Let's just hear it from you, who's winning this is it FaZe?
So is it Cloud9?
Let's get it on it's semifinal time!"
Cloud9 was looking like the best in NA again, and while they weren’t winning every significant
tournament, they were placing well and truly
competing with international rosters.
And then, at the Boston Major, Cloud9 shocked the world by bringing down FaZe Clan 2-1 in
the Grand Finals, becoming the first ever NA Major Champions.
(Casting)
But they did it without n0thing.
N0thing isn’t necessarily upset that his team won the major without him.
In fact, in a certain light, it’s not really his team anyways.
It’s not the team he built, but the org he stuck with.
Not being there for the win hurt, sure, but the way the team fell apart afterwards proved
to him that maybe stepping back from the team was the right call.
"And even thinking about it, obviously just wish I won a Major like every player wishes they won a Major.
but not like "Ah f*ck these guys."
I think it was actually best that the team made those decisions,
to part ways, I probably should have left the team earlier.
or changed something on the team earlier when I had a little bit more,
of a say in what would happen."
N0thing has gone back to play, just a little.
Most notably, he stood in for Mousesports at ESL One Belo Horizonte, and helped the
team to a second place finish in Brazil.
"Yeah I mean I'm here just trying to play some CS, I'm definitely not replacing Oskar,
that guy's a god awper, he's got a special role in this team.
I'm just happy to be here, and not cause them any problems. Be able to stay with the pace they wanna play
I'm proud to say that without a lot of practice I'm still able to show up and do what's necessary to beat top
teams in the world, and I'm just really happy to play in front of this great crowd."
But while playing for Mouz, n0thing got a chance to play with ropz, the team’s rising
young star who cites n0thing as an influence for why he got into CS in the first place.
"I mean I started playing 1.6 when I was around 7,
And that was around the time when n0thing was like the same age as me,
And he had like a lot of these good matches and frag movies,
which I really still look at nowadays.
And yeah he's probably the person I look up to."
as for what comes next?
N0thing says that’s still up in  the air.
"I've created kind of a little ecosystem,
and that's what I'm doing. I'm not opposed to like playing again but the problem is is a lot of teams
want a certain level of commitment.
So all these things are happening and then I'm advising a couple companies passively.
and I've put out this on my stream a couple times, I thought it'd be awesome if I were to play again
to create an org, but you know building an org isn't like "Hey you wanna make an org, like alright cool see ya."
Which, in itself, is a sign of what n0thing has become to CS fans.
It’s been a long time since n0thing was the young hotshot savant he was known for
being in 1.6.
It’s been a long time since he was one of the best players in NA.
It’s been a long time since he’s even been on a successful roster.
But there is something about n0thing that is always true.
N0thing will always be a crowd favourite.
His legacy is one of excellence, but perhaps more importantly, of a player who wasn’t
afraid to pull down the curtain a little, be honest with his fans and teach people about the game.
"So what's cool for me as a streamer right now,
is to keep educating, keep pushing kids to get better cause,
really what keeps the scene thriving, is all the large group of players, the not super competitive guys
having fun playing it because they are trying to get better. Or whatever reason to play with their friends
and sense of community so."
N0thing’s legacy in CS:GO will likely remain forever, but the work he does now, in that
liminal state between player and retired personality, is sealing him in as one of NA’s most important
CS personalities.
The educating he does, the fans he keeps interested in the game, and the ability he has to inspire
young players will only become  more important to the scene as it matures.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.